If you can imagine it, there was a time before time. Well, before clock time, that is. In fact, there were many decades in colonial America when most people had no earthly idea what time it was. Most people, when they keep time, they just stick in the ground and call it noon. They look for the shadows. This is Michael Malley, a historian of time.
如果你能想象的话，在时间出现之前，曾有过一段“时间”。好吧，准确地说是时钟时间出现之前。事实上，在殖民地时期的美国，有几十年的时间，大多数人根本不知道现在几点。大多数人在计时的时候，只是在地上插根棍子，把它叫做正午。他们观察阴影。这位是时间历史学家迈克尔·马利。
What are you going to do when it's cloudy? Well, there's animal cues. You woke up with the rooster and at the end of the day. There's a phrase in American vernacular culture, till the cows come home. Well, the thing is, cows do go back to the barn at a certain time of day. So they could look outside and see the cows heading home, and they would know it was time for them to go home.
阴天的时候你该怎么办？嗯，还有动物的提示。你随着公鸡打鸣醒来，在一天结束时休息。美国俗语里有一句话，“直到奶牛回家”。嗯，事实是，奶牛确实会在一天中的特定时间回到牛棚。所以人们可以看看外面，看到奶牛往家走，他们就知道自己也该回家了。
In the 1650s, the first public clocks were installed in Boston, Salem, and New York. And they were all the rage. New England towns would try to get a clock, and it was a sign of their kind of legitimate. it would be used to call people to prayer or, you know, call people to church or call the meeting. And with this clock tower, suddenly the clock was the center of everything. Being in earshot of the town bells marked the borders of civilization. If you were out of earshot of the town, you were almost in the wilderness.
19世纪50年代，第一批公共时钟被安装在波士顿、塞勒姆和纽约。它们风靡一时。新英格兰的城镇会努力争取安装一个时钟，这被视为一种合法性的标志。它会被用来召唤人们祈祷，或者说，召唤人们去教堂或参加会议。有了这座钟楼，时钟突然成了所有事物的中心。能听到城镇钟声的范围标志着文明的边界。如果你在城镇钟声的范围之外，你就几乎身处荒野了。
Life was becoming organized by the clock. But for the next 100 years, that clock said something different in every city. Noon was one thing in Boston. another in Providence, a third in New York, fine for a farmer, a nightmare for a railroad running on a schedule. So in 1883, the railroad barons got together and tamed this chaos, carving the country into four standard time zones. But for the average American worker, that didn't mean much, especially when your employer could still decide what time it was. The clock calls you to work. You still had to show up to the factory
生活开始被时钟组织起来。但在接下来的100年里，那个时钟在每个城市报出的时间都不一样。波士顿的正午是一个时间，普罗维登斯是另一个，纽约又是第三个，这对农民来说没问题，但对按时刻表运行的铁路来说简直是噩梦。因此在1883年，铁路大亨们聚在一起平息了这种混乱，将全国划分为四个标准时区。但对于普通美国工人来说，这意义不大，尤其是当你的雇主仍然可以决定现在几点的时候。时钟召唤你去工作。你仍然必须在老板敲钟时出现在工厂。
whenever the boss rang the bell. But people don't trust that because they feel like it's always being bumped ahead, you know, to get people in early. Everyone knew the foreman messed with the time to get more work out of you. They could change it. They could make it ahead in the morning and behind in the afternoon, right? They could change it. That's the issue.
无论老板什么时候敲钟。但人们并不信任它，因为他们觉得时间总是被提前，你知道的，为了让人们早点到。每个人都知道工头会搞乱时间来让你多干活。他们可以随意更改。他们可以在早上把时间调快，下午调慢，对吧？他们可以随意更改。这就是问题所在。
So you never know if that clock is accurate. And once you got inside, a human being was often the one deciding whether you were actually on time. So if you know, Joe, the guy checking you in, if he's your buddy, you're going to say, come on, Joe, give me a break. And he's going to mark you as on time when you're not. Or, you know, conversely, if Joe is the tool of management and eager to punish people he doesn't like, he can mark you as late when you're not. Everybody, employees and employers alike, thought this messiness of time was being used to cheat them.
所以你永远不知道那个时钟是否准确。一旦你进了工厂，往往是一个人来决定你是否真的准时。所以，如果你认识负责考勤的乔，如果他是你的哥们儿，你会说：“拜托，乔，通融一下。”他就会在你没准时的时候把你标记为准时。或者，反过来说，如果乔是管理层的走狗，急于惩罚他不喜欢的人，他可以在你没迟到的时候把你标记为迟到。每个人，无论是员工还是雇主，都认为这种时间的混乱被用来欺骗他们。
And into this mess walked an unlikely hero, a man who didn't care much about the factory or power or money. He just cared about clocks. But the clock you built would do more than solve a workplace dispute. It would reorder America's relationship to time itself. From 99% Invisible and BBC Studios, this is a history of the United States in 100 objects. I'm Roman Mars. Today, the Bundy clock and how the first employee time clock
在这片混乱中，出现了一位不太可能的英雄，一个不太关心工厂、权力和金钱的人。他只关心时钟。但他制造的时钟所做的不仅仅是解决职场纠纷。它将重塑美国与时间本身的关系。来自《99%隐形》和BBC工作室，这是《100件物品中的美国史》。我是罗曼·马斯。今天，邦迪时钟以及第一台员工考勤钟如何引发了一场职场监控和效率的革命。记者艾莉·莱特富特带来了这个故事。我们这位不太可能的英雄，这位无意中改变了我们与时间关系的人，名叫威拉德·邦迪。威拉德出生于1845年，在纽约州奥本市长大，那是一个位于该州中心地带、规模虽小但蓬勃发展的工厂城镇。小时候，他是个工程天才。
sparked a revolution in workplace surveillance and efficiency. Reporter Ellie Lightfoot has the story. The name of our unlikely hero, this man who would unwittingly change our relationship to time, he's called Willard Bundy. Willard was born in 1845 and grew up in Auburn, New York, a small but booming factory town in the center of the state. As a boy, he was kind of an engineering whiz kid.
他喜欢摆弄东西，制作小玩具。这位是汤姆·帕泽克。他在邦迪博物馆工作，你可以想象，那里全是关于威拉德·邦迪的内容。小时候，他喜欢拆开手表并尝试重新组装它们。威拉德长大后成为了一名专业的钟表修理工、珠宝商，因为在那个年代，珠宝商不仅仅是珠宝商。他们是镇上的时间权威。他们的职责是制造这些大型、精确的时钟，并把它们展示在店面的橱窗里，以便人们
He liked tinkering with things, he built little toys. This is Tompazek. He works at the Bundy Museum, which, as you can imagine, is all about Willard Bundy. As a child, he would like take apart watches and try to reassemble them. Willard grew up to become a professional watchtinkerer, a jeweler, because back then, jewelers weren't just jewelers. They were the town's authority on time. It was their responsibility to build these big, accurate clocks and keep them on display in their shop window so that people
可以去橱窗看看现在几点。而这份工作中威拉德最喜欢的就是这一部分。他会花上数小时甚至数天来构建这些复杂的创意时钟，比如这个他声称可以保持一千年精准时间的八英尺高的庞然大物。它不仅有显示时、分、秒的表盘，还有星期、日期、月份以及未来一千年的年份。但这个时钟，顺便说一下，他称之为“奇妙时钟”，不仅仅是为了报时。它还有每小时都会鸣响的铃铛和哨子。
could visit the window and see what time it was. And it was this part of the job that Willard loved the most. He'd spent hours and hours constructing these intricate novelty clocks, like this hulking eight-foot-tall clock that he claimed could keep perfect time for a thousand years. It had dials for not only hours, minutes, and seconds, but also the day of the week, the date of the month, which particular month it was, and the year for 1,000 years. But this clock, which, by the way, he called the wonderful clock, wasn't, just for telling time. It had bells and whistles that would chime on the hour, every hour.
这东西本质上就是一个加强版的布谷鸟钟。但威拉德没有让鸟儿跳出来，而是构建了一个精致的场景，一种工作磨坊的机械立体模型。我想那实际上是一个木材加工厂，所以瀑布在运输小木头去切割。还有一个带有青蛙、乌龟和各种鱼类的小池塘。有一个微型蒸汽机和一条在池塘里漂浮的小船。这个时钟太受欢迎了，太奇特了，
The thing was essentially a cuckoo clock on steroids. But instead of a bird popping out, Willard constructed this elaborate scene, a kind of mechanical diorama of a working mill. I think it's a lumber mill, actually, so the waterfall is transporting little logs to be cut. There was also a tiny pond with frogs and turtles and fish of every kind. There was a mini steam engine and a boat bobbing in the pond. This clock was so popular, such an oddity,
以至于门口必须有一名警察，负责维持人群秩序。因为人们被它迷住了，以至于他们只是在店前徘徊。威拉德将3000多个微小的零件拼凑成了一件杰作，这对我来说至少说明这个男人热爱秩序。所以，这真的不足为奇，
that there actually had to be a police officer out front, just kind of keeping the crowd moving along. Because people were so enchanted by it that they would just loiter in front of his store. Willard had wrangled over 3,000 tiny pieces into a kind of masterpiece, which, to me at least, tells me that the man loved order. So it's not surprising, really,
他将美国各地工厂中计时混乱的现象视为一个他需要解决的巨大问题。故事是这样的，有一天，威拉德走进镇上的一家工厂，看到了老板们是如何记录员工时间的。他们给每个工人分配了一个小黄铜圆盘，并要求他们每天早上把它扔进桶里以标记自己到岗。但这个系统一团糟。它很草率。
that he saw the messiness of timekeeping happening in factories across America as a giant problem he needed to solve. The story goes that one day, Willard walked into a factory in his town and saw how the bosses were keeping track of their employees' time. They assigned each worker one of these little brass discs and expected them to toss it into a bucket every morning to mark themselves present. But the system was a mess. It was sloppy.
没有关于工人实际到达时间的准确记录。威拉德无法控制自己。他看到了一个现存的系统，但它不够好。于是回到店里，威拉德开始制造一些足够好的东西。1888年，他申请了专利，这就是第一台员工考勤钟——邦迪时钟。它基本上是一个挂在墙上的华丽木箱，有点像落地钟。除了钟面下方有一个插钥匙的小槽。每个工人都有自己的钥匙。
There was no accurate record of when the guy actually showed up. And Willard, he couldn't help himself. He saw a system that existed, but it wasn't up to snuff. So back in his shop, Willard started building something that was up to snuff. And in 1888, he patented it, the first employee time clock, the Bundy clock. It was basically an ornate wooden box mounted on the wall, kind of like a grandfather clock. Except underneath the clock face, there was a little slot for a key. Each worker got their own key.
每天早上，当他们来上班时，他们会把钥匙插入槽中，转动四分之一圈，这就会在纸带上印下他们到达的确切时间。但在申请专利后，威拉德对销售它的想法并不太感兴趣。我想威拉德满足于守住自己的本分。他想制造那些带给他快乐的特定物品。他并不一定想发财。他并没有试图重新定义这个系统。也许威拉德不想发财，但他的兄弟想。
And every morning, when they showed up to work, they'd insert their key into the slot. turn it a quarter turn, which would then stamp the exact time they got there onto a ribbon of paper. But after he patented it, Willard wasn't really that into the idea of selling it. Willard was content to stay in his lane, I guess. He wanted to make these very specific objects that brought him joy. He wasn't necessarily looking to get rich. He wasn't trying to redefine the system. Maybe Willard wasn't trying to get rich, but his brother was,
威拉德的弟弟哈洛将在邦迪时钟的故事中扮演重要角色。但哈洛想要威拉德不想要的东西。事实上，邦迪兄弟俩的性格截然不同。很明显，我们这位博物馆的讲解员有偏爱。我们所知道的关于威拉德的一切都告诉我们，他是一个真正的好人。他在社区里很受欢迎。他的弟弟哈洛则完全相反。他粗鲁。
Willard's younger brother Harlow is going to play a huge role in the story of the Bundy Clock. But Harlow wants things Willard doesn't. In fact, the Bundy brothers couldn't have been more different. And it's clear our museum man has a favorite. Everything that we know about Willard tells us that he was a genuinely nice guy. He was well liked in the community. His younger brother Harlow was the complete opposite. He was rude.
他生硬。他是个混蛋。而威拉德，这位发明家，是个心肠软的人。据说，他简直是你所能想到的最浪漫的人。哈洛则不然。他在镇上的名声很差。威拉德很乐意花20年时间制造一个时钟。但哈洛，那个有商业头脑的兄弟，几乎立刻就看到了金钱的诱惑。
He was curt. He was a jerk. while Willard, the inventor, was a softie. Supposedly, he was just like the most romantic man that you can think of. Harlow was not. He had a very poor reputation throughout town. Willard was more than happy to spend 20 years making a single clock. But Harlow, the brother with the business mine, saw the dollar signs almost immediately.
他意识到他哥哥正在发明什么。他说：“嘿，如果我们推销这些时钟，它们会像热卖的蛋糕一样畅销。”最终，哈洛说服了他的发明家哥哥与他合伙做生意。但邦迪时钟并没有像热卖的蛋糕那样立即畅销。许多企业主并不一定觉得需要这样的考勤钟。此外，这个时钟很贵。一台邦迪时钟要75美元，我想这相当于现在的1500到2000美元。另一个问题是，第一年他们试图直接向工人推销这些时钟。
He was aware of what his brother was inventing. He said, hey, if we market these clocks, they're going to sell like hot cakes. Eventually, Harlow convinces his inventor brother to go into business with him. But the Bundy clocks do not immediately sell, like hotcakes. A lot of business owners didn't necessarily see the need for a time clock like this. Plus, this clock was expensive. A Bundy clock was $75, which I want to say that calculates to about $1,500 to $2,000. The other problem was that for the first year, they tried to market these clocks directly to workers.
他们会在工会杂志或工厂城镇的报纸上刊登广告，上面写着：“嘿，工厂工人，确保你的老板付给你的工资是正确的，鼓励他买一台邦迪时钟。”但这个策略结果是一个巨大的失败。如果你的想法是让所有的同事都团结在这个设备周围，并告诉你的老板去买它，他们是不会这么做的。你知道，他们会做那些能为自己省钱的事。老板们根本不会听工人的。所以很快他们就放弃了这个想法。公司里的某个人想出了一个天才的主意，改变了策略。
They would take out ads in union magazines or newspapers in factory towns that would read, Hey, factory worker, make sure your boss is paying you correctly, encourage him to buy a Bundy clock. But this strategy turned out to be a big old flop. If the idea was you get all of your coworkers to rally around this device and tell your boss to buy it, they're not going to do it. You know, they're going to do what saves them money. The bosses weren't going to listen to their workers. So pretty soon they dump that idea. Someone at the company has the genius idea of flipping the script.
他们刊登了广告，上面写着：“嘿，工厂主们。确保你没有被懒惰、不诚实的工人欺骗。买一台邦迪时钟，追踪他们的工时。”叮，叮，叮。说中了。然后，他们开始热销。我们不确定是哪个兄弟想出了这个主意。但在汤姆看来，这很典型是哈洛的风格。
They put out ads that read, Hey, factory owners. Make sure you aren't being cheated by your lazy, dishonest workers. By a Bundy clock, track their hours. Ding, ding, ding. Nailed it. And, you know, then they start selling. We don't know for certain witch brother. came up with this. But in Tom's mind, this is classic Harlow.
我倾向于认为哈洛负责广告。根据我们对他性格和举止的了解，很多早期的广告听起来像是他写的。它们有点咄咄逼人。比如，有一张广告就是一只巨大的斗牛犬的照片。这是一只斗牛犬的头咬穿了一本考勤账簿，标题写着：“在你的工资单上放一只看门狗。”这个新的广告活动奏效了。到1898年，他们有9000台时钟在流通，并占据了市场主导地位。
I'd like to think Harlow was in charge of the advertisement. With everything that we know about his character and demeanor, a lot of the early ads sound like he wrote them. They were just kind of aggressive. Like, there's this one that's just a giant picture of a bulldog. It's the head of a bulldog biting through a time ledger, a time sheet, and the caption reads, put a watchdog on your payroll. This new ad campaign, it works. By 1898, they've got 9,000 of their clocks in circulation and are just dominating the market.
但后来，在世纪之交，邦迪兄弟与打卡钟的制造商联手了，这是一种新的发明，工人不需要再摆弄钥匙。他们只需要插入一张纸，拉动杠杆，就能盖上印章。在哈洛疯狂推销之后，这些时钟确实像热卖的蛋糕一样畅销。这些时钟卖得这么好的部分原因是它们利用了日益增长的需求。在工业化的这个阶段，生产规模正在迅速扩大。工厂雇佣了成千上万的人，规模非常庞大。历史学家迈克尔·马利再次表示，在此之前，当工厂规模较小时。
But then, around the turn of the century, the Bundys joined forces with the makers of the punch clock, a new invention where workers wouldn't need to fuss with a key. They could just insert a piece of paper, pull a lever, and stamp it. And after Harlow markets the hell out of it, these clocks actually do sell like hotcakes. And part of the reason that these clocks sell so well is because they tap into a growing demand. At this point in industrialization, the scale of production is really ramping up. Factories are employing thousands of people and they're vast in their size. Historian Michael Malley again, he says that before this, when factories were smaller.
对员工的监控很容易。例如，本·富兰克林是一名印刷工，他住在印刷店楼上。所以他的员工或多或少都在富兰克林拥有的房子里。他一直能看到他们。他知道他们昨晚喝醉了，因为他听到了。因此，随着老板雇佣越来越多的工人，那些他们无法亲眼看到的工人，他们开始认为自己面临着一个新的生存问题。他们无法识别谁是好工人，谁是坏工人。
Surveillance of your employees is easy. Like, for example, Ben Franklin is a printer and he lives above his print shop. So his employees are more or less in a house belonging to Franklin. He sees them all the time. He knows they got drunk last night because he heard them. So as the bosses hire more and more workers, ones they couldn't physically see, they began to think of themselves as facing this new existential problem. They can't identify who's a good worker, who's a bad worker.
他们不知道谁在努力工作，谁没有，因为规模变得太大了。于是邦迪兄弟带着解决方案出现了。他们说，用我们的机器来监控你的员工。他们正在推销一种新的分类工人的方式，不是由人来分类，而是由时钟来分类。看看迈克喜欢指出的那张邦迪时钟的旧广告。这是一张1911年的广告。太阴险了。在顶部，有一个巨大的时钟和一长排等待打卡的工人。
They don't know who's working hard and who's not because the scale has become too big. So in come the Bundy brothers with a fix. They're saying, use our machine to surveil your employees. They're selling a new way to sort workers, not by a human, by the clock. Just look at this old ad for a Bundy clock that Mike loves to point to. Here's an ad from 1911. That's so sinister. At the top, there's this massive clock and a long line of workers waiting to clock in.
有男工也有女工。他们中有些人穿得很好，有些人穿得像劳工。还有一些只是黑色的剪影。因为他们迟到了，他们被时钟发现了他们的懒散。时钟射出箭头，指向这些懒汉，文字写着：“邦迪时钟指出你那些无利可图的员工。”现在你可以把高效的员工从低效的员工中筛选出来了。关于准时性的道德判断非常明显，准时是一种美德，迟到是一种罪恶。
There's working men and working women. And some of them are kind of well-dressed and some of them are dressed like laborers. And some of them are just dark silhouette. because they showed up late, and they were able to be discovered in their slackerhood by the clock. There's arrows shooting out from the clock, pointing to these slackers, with a line of text that reads, The Bundy Clock points out your improfitable employees. Now you can sift out the efficient employees from the inefficient. The element of moral judgment is really pronounced about punctuality, and its punctuality is a virtue, lateness is a sin.
这些广告显示，邦迪兄弟卖的不仅仅是一种记录员工时间的方法。他们卖的是一种新的道德结构。很简单。如果你准时，你从根本上就是好的。如果你不准时，你从根本上就是坏的。功绩被重新想象的方式之一，就是一个人拥有了这些内在化的、机器般的准时习惯。但工人们抵制将这些机器般的准时习惯内在化。事实上，他们讨厌它。
These ads reveal that the Bundy Brothers were selling more than just a way of keeping track of your employees. They were selling a new moral structure. It's simple. If you're on time, you're fundamentally good. If you're not, you're fundamentally bad. One of the ways that Merritt gets reimagined, it's someone who has these internalized, these machine-like habits of punctuality. But the workers resisted internalizing these machine-like habits of punctuality. Actually, they hated it.
这在很大程度上是你的老板含蓄地表示他们不信任你？而且，如果你准时，其实也不再重要了。因为如果你在一家有一千名工人的工厂工作，你必须排长队打卡。为了排队而提前到场是一种强加。你知道，如果你的班次是七点开始，希望你能在七点或稍微早一点打卡。现在，如果你没做到，每个人都会知道。
was very much an instance of your boss implicitly saying that they don't trust you? Also, it doesn't actually matter anymore if you're on time. Because if you work in a factory with a thousand workers, you're going to have to wait in a long line to clock in. There's an imposition to show up early to stand in line. You know, if your shift starts at seven, hopefully you can clock in at seven or a little bit earlier. And now, if you didn't, everyone would know.
有一个非常响亮的铃声响起，所以你在工厂的噪音中会被听到，你会想象有人过来对你大喊大叫。还有一个数字的问题。你被分配了一把带有员工编号的钥匙。所以，与其说是约翰·多伊或简·史密斯，你现在是20号员工。事实上，邦迪博物馆的汤姆发现了1890年代邮政工人制作的政治漫画，工人们正向邦迪时钟投掷飞镖，破坏时钟。
There's a very loud bell that goes off, so you'd be heard over the noise of a factory and you'd imagine where no one'd come and yell at you. And then there's a whole number thing. You were assigned a key with an employee number on it. So rather than, you know, John Doe or Jane Smith, you're now employee number 20. In fact, Tom at the Bundy Museum found these political cartoons made by postal workers in the 1890s, where the workers are just hurling darts at the Bundy clock. vandalizing the clocks.
有许多关于邦迪时钟受欢迎程度极低的政治漫画、诗歌或歌曲。但工人们怎么想并不重要。老板们有了一种监控员工的新方法，他们很喜欢。但这仅仅是个开始，
There were a number of political cartoons or poems or songs written about just how poor of a reception Bundy clocks had. But it doesn't matter what the workers think. The bosses had a new way to surveil their employees and they loved it. But that's just the beginning,
因为还有另一个人要来了，一个要把邦迪的发明推向极致的人。不仅仅是为了追踪人们什么时候到场，而是为了控制他们如何工作，测量他们一天中的每一秒。当邦迪兄弟在全国各地的工厂推销他们的时钟时，在大约200英里南边的费城，还有另一个人也对时间感兴趣，
because there's another guy coming in, a guy who's going to take Bundy's invention to the extreme. Not just to track when people show up, but to control how, they work to measure every single second of their day. While the Bundys are out there selling their clocks to factories across the country, about 200 miles south in Philadelphia, there's another guy who's also interested in time
以一种强迫症的方式。他即将接手邦迪时钟，并彻底改变它的使用方式。他的名字叫弗雷德里克·泰勒。泰勒是个怪人。他出生于费城的上流社会。他的家庭进行欧洲大巡游。他们有仆人。他们有仆人。他们有一栋房子，博克斯利，他们有一个庄园。所以他们生来就享有特权，他本可以无所事事。但泰勒不是为闲散、休息或娱乐而生的。举个例子，经典的休闲游戏槌球。当轮到泰勒时，他会让朋友们等着，而他蹲下来测量从哪个角度接近球的每一个可能的角度。只有这样，有了这些数据，他才能计算出球需要遵循的确切矢量，以便
in kind of an obsessive way. He's about to take the Bundy Clock and completely change how it's used. His name is Frederick Taylor. He's a weird guy, Taylor. So he's born to the Philadelphia upper class. His family does the grand tour of Europe. They have servants. They have servants. They have a house, Boxley, they have an estate. And so they're born to privilege, and he could have been idle. But Taylor wasn't built for idleness, or a rest, or fun, really. Take, for instance, the classic leisure game of Croquet. When it came time for Taylor's turn, he'd make his friends wait while he squatted down to measure every possible angle from which one could approach the ball. Only then, with this data, could he calculate the exact vector the ball needed to follow in order to
准确地穿过球门。随着弗雷德·泰勒长大，他继续保持着某种古怪。他没有像他父亲那样进入常春藤盟校，而是决定在费城的一家液压工厂当学徒。这是一个奇怪的举动。他的家人有点像，弗雷德怎么了，你知道吗？但他热爱这份工作。他热爱它。
passed through the hoop accurately. As Fred Taylor grew up, he continued to be kind of odd. Instead of going on to an Ivy League, as his father had, he decided to apprentice at a hydraulics factory in Philly. It's a weird move to make. And his family is kind of like, what's wrong with Fred, you know? But he loves the work. He loves it.
他热爱用双手工作。他无法相信他周围的工人能做什么。泰勒真的被这些人迷住了，因为他们正在制造，你知道，蒸汽机的大气缸，大型重工业零件。事实上，他太着迷了，以至于他非常努力地融入其中。他开始像他们一样穿衣，像他们一样说话，经常骂人。你知道，讲黄色笑话，下班后去酒吧等等。但在内心深处，弗雷德·泰勒真的不像这些人。
He loves working with his hands. And he can't believe what the workers around him are capable of. Taylor is really dazzled by these guys because they're making, you know, big cylinders for a steam engine, big heavy industrial parts. And he was so dazzled, actually, that he tried very hard to blend in. He started dressing like them, talking like them, swearing a lot. You know, telling dirty jokes and going to the bar after work and things like that. But on the inside, Fred Taylor is really not like these guys.
他带着一种与生俱来的优越感来到车间。对。就像费城上流社会臭名昭著一样。我来自费城。我的一个朋友来自费城上流社会。美国没有比费城上流社会更势利的人了。而且，你知道，他们比其他任何人都优越。他在那种他应该掌控全局的感觉中长大。
He comes to the shop floor with an innate sense of superiority. Right. Like if Philadelphia upper class is notorious. I'm from Philly. One of my friends is from the Philadelphia upper classes. There's no greater snobs in America than Philadelphia upper class. And, you know, they're superior to everybody else. And he grows up with that sense that he should be running the show.
在裙带关系的帮助下，他很快就做到了。泰勒在路边的一家钢铁厂被录用，他的父母是工厂老板的朋友。他被提升为工头，立刻，他开始对他所认为的懒惰发动战争。他说工人们总是故意偷懒，因为他们知道如果他们做得更多，他们每天就会被要求做得更多。
And with a sprinkle of nepotism, he soon is. Taylor gets hired at a steel factory down the road where his parents were friends with the factory's owners. He gets promoted to foremen, and right away, he begins to wage a war on what he saw as laziness. He said workers were always guilty of slacking on purpose because they know if they do more, they're going to be asked to do more every day.
然后他们会被要求做得更多，而他们不会得到更多的钱。泰勒的第一个策略是激励最快的工人多生产，如果你比旁边的人做得多，就多拿几块钱。但工人们团结一致，继续以他们一贯的速度工作。所以相反，泰勒有一天带着秒表出现在车间。他的计划是专注于一个执行单一任务的工人，并为它的每一个方面计时。
And then they're going to ask to do yet more, and they won't get any more money. Taylor's first strategy was to incentivize the fastest workers to produce more, a few extra bucks if you make more than the guy next to you. But the workers stuck together and kept making things at the pace they always had. So instead, Taylor shows up one day to the shop floor with a stopwatch. His plan was to focus on one worker performing a single, task and time every aspect of it.
假设我在车间工作。工人用来塑造钢材的东西。他会坐在那里拿着秒表，看着我工作。泰勒会在看到他做任何他认为有成效的事情时启动时钟。但当我做他认为没有成效的事情时，他会停止秒表。所谓没有成效，泰勒指的是任何像人的行为。比如和邻居说话，“嘿，弗雷德，费城人队怎么样？”或者如果他提裤子，或者他走过去拿另一个，
Let's say I'm working in a lane. The thing workers would use to shape steel. And he'd sit there with his stopwatch and he'd watch me work. Taylor would start the clock when he saw him doing anything he thought to be productive. But when I did things he thought were unproductive, he would stop the stopwatch. By unproductive, Taylor meant anything resembling human. Like talk to his neighbor, hey, Fred, how about those fillies? Or if he hitches up his pants or he walks over to get another,
工具，泰勒会停止秒表。当工作完成后，泰勒会剔除所有这些所谓的“浪费动作”，以得出他所谓的完成任何工作所需的“标准时间”。众所周知，他把这一点扩展到了铲煤。所以在伯利恒钢铁公司，他尝试了这个方法，实际上有一个铲煤棚，你必须去那里报到。你会说，“是的，我在这儿，我要铲煤，这种煤。”然后，“好的，这是你的铲子，史密斯，这是你要使用的动作。”
tool, Taylor will stop the stopwatch. When the job was done, Taylor would cut out all of these unproductive, quote-unquote, waste movements to land on what he called was the standard time it took to do any job. Famously, he extends that to shoveling. So at Bethlehem Steel, where he tries this, there's actually a shovel shed that you have to report to. And you'll say, yeah, I'm here, I'm going to do shoveling, this kind of coal. And, okay, here's your shovel, Smith, and this is the motion you're going to use.
“你要用这个动作做这么久，然后你要休息这么久，然后你要回去，在一天结束时，你应该能够移动三吨煤。”但实际上，这些时间在物理上是不可能的。没有人能保持那种速度。质量会下滑。你知道，我的身体会受苦。
and you're going to do it for this long, in this motion, and then you're going to take a break for this long, and then you're going to go back, and at the end of the day, you should be able to move three tons of coal. But in reality, these times were just physically impossible. No one can keep that pace. The quality will slip. You know, I'll suffer physically.
尽管如此，泰勒还是强制执行了这些标准时间。跟不上的工人会被扣工资，或者更常见的是，直接被解雇。像邦迪兄弟一样，泰勒利用时钟将人分为几类：能按时完成任务的是“一流人才”，不能完成的是“二流人才”。难怪工厂里的工人们绝对讨厌他。他们当面叫他傻瓜、暴君，甚至是奴隶监工。情况变得非常糟糕，工人们开始破坏他们自己的设备，这样如果他们没达到配额，他们就可以说是机器的错，而不是他们的错。当这招不管用时，他们就开始直接威胁他。他们告诉他注意他的生意。
Despite this, Taylor enforces these standard times anyways. The workers who can't keep up are docked pay, or more often, just axed entirely. And like the Bundys, Taylor uses the clock to create these categories of men, first-class men for those who complete the task in time, second-class men for those who don't. It's not surprising the men at the factory absolutely hate it. They call him a fool, a tyrant, even a slave driver right to his face. It gets so bad that the workers start sabotaging their own equipment so that if they miss a quota, they can say it's the machine's fault, not theirs. And when that doesn't work, they just start threatening him directly. They tell him to watch his business.
在他回家的路上。就在这时，大约十年后，泰勒决定是时候离开费城，把他的管理哲学带到路上去了。他把自己提升为第一位所谓的效率专家、效率顾问。只是这比那更极端一点。是的，你看，这是“效率福音”。这有点像耶稣，如果他不是把水变成酒，而是给你的工作计时，并要求你快30%完成。像耶稣一样，泰勒开始聚集门徒。我称他们为“泰勒主义者”，我们训练他们传播效率的福音
back on his walk home. And it's at this point, about a decade in, that Taylor decides it's time to leave Philly and take his managerial philosophy on the road. He advances himself as the first sort of efficiency expert, efficiency consultant. Except it's a bit more extreme than that. Yeah, see, it's the gospel of efficiency. It's kind of like Jesus if, instead of him turning water into wine, he timed how long it took you to do it and demanded you do it 30% faster. And like Jesus, Taylor starts gathering up disciples. I'll call them Taylorites, who we trained to spread the good word of efficiency
到全国各地的其他工厂和纺织厂。但泰勒扩张的关键，经常被忽视的部分，实际上是打卡钟，邦迪和他的新公司创造的那种。这对泰勒来说是核心。因为随着工厂规模变大，用真人来执行泰勒的标准时间
to other factories and textile mills across the country. But the key to Taylor's expansion, the part that's often overlooked, is actually the punch clock, the one Bundy and his new company created. It was central to Taylor. Because as factories got bigger, enforcing Taylor's standard time with actual humans
变得几乎不可能。老板不想站在那里看着他。“快点，施密特。”所以相反，执行者的工作交给了时钟。现在，每个工位都有一个打卡钟，用来记录工人完成每项任务所需的时间。所以他应该去，“砰”，打卡，开始，做这件事，做完后再打卡。
became practically impossible. The boss doesn't want to stand there watching him. Come on, Schmidt. So instead, the job of the enforcer went to a clock. Now, there's a punch clock at every station to time how long it takes a worker to do every task. So he's supposed to go, boom, punch the clock, start, do the thing, punch the clock when he's done.
这是仅仅打卡上班的逻辑延伸。这是邦迪时钟所引入的逻辑延伸。因为现在，不仅仅是早上打卡上班，晚上打卡下班，工作的每一部分都有自己的打卡记录。每一刻都被计时、机械化了。但这种打卡钟的使用，实际上还做了另一件事。它意外地发明了一个全新的工作类别。因为在轮班结束时，工人们会把他们的小考勤卡交给泰勒
It's the logical extension of just clocking in. The logical extension of what the Bundy clock introduced. Because now, instead of just clocking in, in the morning and out at night, each part of the job gets its own punch in and out. Each moment is timed, mechanized. But this use of the punch clock, it actually does something else. It accidentally invents a whole new category of job. Because at the end of their shift, workers would hand in their little time cards to what Taylor
所谓的“中央计划办公室”。会有全体员工。他们收集那些卡片并说，“你知道，你没有在正确的时间做这件事，或者你在这件事上花了太长时间。”这些人不是老板。他们不是工人。他们不是工头。他们是这种新型的官僚，
called the central planning office. There would be an entire staff. They collect those cards and say, you know, you didn't do it at the right time or you took too long on this. And these people aren't bosses. They're not workers. They're not foremen. They're this new type of bureaucrat
他们的唯一工作就是管理别人的时间。本质上，他们是国家的第一批中层管理者。这种效率扩张。一切都按计划进行，直到泰勒在波士顿郊外的一家美国陆军设施被录用，名为沃特敦兵工厂。这是泰勒主义将面临最大挑战的地方。泰勒被雇来做他的一项
whose only job is managing other people's time. Essentially, they're the nation's first middle managers. The sufficiency expansion. It's all going according to plan until Taylor gets hired at a U.S. Army facility outside of Boston called Watertown Arsenal. This is where Taylorism is going to face its biggest challenge yet. Taylor is hired to come in and do one of his
效率研究，这意味着他要进行这种秒表时间研究。所以他和他的秒表门徒大军出现，开始极其仔细地为一切计时。想象一下你正在用钢材塑造这些复杂的零件。你整个轮班都弯腰在工作台上。我说的是90度折叠成两半。你的脸离它几英寸。而站在你正上方，盯着你的头顶看的是很多
efficiency studies, and that means he's going to do this stopwatch time study. So he and his army of stopwatch wielding disciples show up and start timing everything incredibly closely. Imagine you're molding these intricate parts out of steel. You spend your entire shift bent over your workbench. I'm talking 90 degrees folded in half. Your face inches from it. And standing directly over you, staring down at the top of your head, is a lot of the
头是一个穿着三件套西装的泰勒主义者，手里拿着秒表。几个小时后，你需要站直一会儿，伸展一下背部，也许擦掉眼里的汗水。但就在你这么做的那一刻，你听到了他的手表咔哒一声。他在计时。他在记下来。对他来说，这些是浪费动作。他甚至把它简化到有时建议把秒表藏在书里。他的出版物中有一张照片，是一本被挖空的书，里面放着一个秒表。所以我只是在读这本迷人的小说，但实际上我，你知道，我在监控你。他们非常生气。
head is a tailor right in a three-piece suit, stopwatch in hand. After hours of this, you're going to need to stand up straight for a second, stretch your back, maybe wipe the sweat from your eyes. But the moment you do, you hear the click of his watch. He's timing it. He's writing it down. For him, these are waist movements. He's actually got it down to where he sometimes recommends hiding the stopwatch in a book. There's a picture in one of his publications of a book that's been cut away and a stopwatch inside. So I'm just reading this fascinating novel, but actually I'm, you You know, I'm surveilling you. They get really upset.
他们变得非常倔强。如果可以的话，他们会把他赶走。对我来说，这是故事变得非常有趣的地方。我只能称之为“时钟战争”的开始。因为就在这里，工人们决定使用他们自己的怀表。他们说，如果他们看到泰勒主义者在计时，他们也会计时。他们必须能够说，“不，你停得太早了，对吧？”或者“这是我做这件事所需的时间。”
They get really truculent. And if they can, they'll drive him away. This, for me, is where the story gets really interesting. The start of what I can only describe as clock warfare. Because it's here that the workers decide to put their own pocket watches to use. They say, if they see a Taylorite timing something, they're going to time it too. They have to be able to say, no, you stop that too soon, right? Or this is how long it takes me to do it.
“我自己计时了。”对吧，砰，我自己计时了。你不知道怎么做。有一天，一个泰勒主义者开始为一个工人做工作时计时。泰勒主义者说这项工作应该花24分钟。工人说他计时时花了50分钟。他被要求快两倍地工作。这绝对不行。
I timed myself. right, boom, I timed myself. You don't know how to do it. One day, a tailor right starts timing one of the workers while he does a job. The tailor right says the job should take 24 minutes. The worker says that when he timed it, it took 50. He's being told to work twice as fast. And this could not stand.
那天晚上，他们聚在一起达成了一项协议。他们说，下次泰勒主义者试图用秒表研究我们时，我们就停止工作。第二天，这件事就发生了。一个泰勒主义者拿着秒表走到一个工人面前，这次那个人只是拒绝配合。他立刻被解雇了，他的同事们看着这一切，在他身后走出了工厂。最终，工厂里的情况变得如此激烈，以至于在1912年，举行了一场全面的国会听证会来调查泰勒主义，以及他的效率方法是否在损害政府的工人。
That night, they meet up and come to an agreement. They say, the next time a tailor right tries to study us with the stopwatch, we'll just stop working. And the very next day, that happens. a Taylorite comes up to a worker with a stopwatch, and this time the guy just refuses to go along with it. He gets fired immediately, and his fellow workers, watching all of this, walk out behind him. Eventually, things at the factory get so heated that in 1912, there's a full congressional hearing to investigate Taylorism, and whether his efficiency methods were damaging the government's workers.
工人们作证说：“我们不反对努力工作。我们为我们的技能感到自豪，我们为我们的工艺感到自豪，我们为我们完成工作的能力感到自豪。我们反对的是被秒表驱动。”这是罗曼在读他们说的真实话语。“我不反对他们找出需要多长时间，但我反对他们拿着秒表站在我身边，好像我是赛马或汽车一样。我们的反对意见是有人站在你身边像奴隶监工一样。秒表等同于鞭子。你还不如直接用那个。”
Workers testify, we don't object to working hard. We are proud of our skill and we're proud of our craft and we're proud of our ability to get the job done. We do object to being driven by a stopwatch. This is Roman reading the actual words they said. I don't object to their finding out how long it takes, but I do object to there standing over me with a stopwatch as if I was a racehorse or an automobile. Our objection is to having someone standing over you as a slave driver. The stopwatch is equivalent to a whip. You might just as well have that.
工人们一次又一次地提到秒表是问题所在。正是这个物体夺走了他们的自由。一位工会领袖作证说：“它抹杀了机械师的个性。它只是让他成为机器的一部分。他不再为自己思考。他有别人为他思考。作为熟练工匠的意义将被实质性地贬低。”
The workers again and again refer to the stopwatch as the problem. It was this object that was taking away their freedom. One union leader testified, It wipes out the individuality of a mechanic. It simply makes him part of a machine. He does not think for himself. He has others to think for him. The meaning of being a skilled artisan will have been materially degraded.
“你知道，我将无法控制我的劳动节奏。我将被变成一个机器般的实体。”当轮到泰勒主义者站上证人席时，他们并没有回避这一点。事实上，他们变本加厉。他们说，在我们的系统中，工人们是字面意义上的机器，正如其中一人所说。“人是一个便携式发电厂。他这里有一个锅炉，胃，消耗食物。这些过程与在炉排中燃烧煤炭没有什么不同。”
You know, I won't have control over the pace in terms of my labor. I'll be made into a machine-like entity. When it's their turn to take the stand, the tailor rides don't shy away from this. Actually, they double down. They're like, in our system, working men are literal machines, as one of them put it. A man is a portable power plant. He has a boiler down here, the stomach, which consumes food. The processes are not dissimilar to burning coal in the grate.
“他这里有一个引擎，他的心脏，是一个泵。”但参议员们根本不吃这一套。他们因为愤怒而面红耳赤。你在证词中看不到这一点，因为它是经过编辑的，但他们互相咒骂，互相挥舞拳头。最终，工人们实际上赢了。泰勒主义和秒表在政府经营的工厂中被禁止，直到1949年。但对迈克来说，这次胜利并不是真正的胜利。
He has an engine in here, his heart, which is a pump. But the senators are not having any of this. They're red-faced with rage at each other. You don't see this in the testimony because it's edited, but they're cursing at each other and shaking their fists at each other. In the end, the workers actually win. Taylorism and stopwatches are banned from government-run factories until 1949. But to Mike, this win wasn't really a win.
它代表了美国历史上的一个转折点，工人们停止了与机械时间本身的斗争，实际上，在某种程度上，接受了它。因为尽管他们说他们讨厌秒表，但兵工厂的工人们并没有试图摆脱它们或像第一批邦迪时钟的工人们那样破坏它们。事实上恰恰相反。为了对抗秒表，他们带来了自己的秒表。
It represents this turning point in American history where workers stopped fighting against mechanical time itself and actually, in a way, kind of embraced it. Because as much as they said they hated the... the stopwatches, the workers at the arsenal weren't trying to get rid of them or vandalize them like workers had with the first Bundy clocks. It was actually the opposite. To fight the stopwatches, they brought their own.
没有办法绕过它，对吧？除了用时钟，没有办法对抗这个，你必须能够使用管理者的语言来对抗管理者。他们必须采用压迫者的语言来从压迫中解放自己，所以你真的自由了吗，对吧？我自由地打卡。就是这样。泰勒在沃特敦调查后仅几年就去世了，但他的门徒们还活着，并且传播着效率的福音，远远超出了工厂的围墙，
There's no way around it, right? There's no way to combat this except with clocks, and you're going to have to be able to use the language of the manager to combat the manager. They have to adopt the language of the oppressor to free themselves from oppression, so are you really free, right? I'm free to punch a clock. that's that. Taylor died only a few years after the investigation at Watertown, but his disciples were alive and kicking, spreading the good word of efficiency far beyond the walls of the factory,
到办公室，到学校，到医院。事实上，哈佛商学院将其大部分早期课程建立在泰勒的思想之上。泰勒主义甚至被他的两个最亲密的门徒，一对名叫弗兰克和莉莲·吉尔布雷斯的夫妇带入了美国家庭。弗兰克和莉莲·吉尔布雷斯，他们是一对已婚夫妇。弗兰克是一名砖瓦承包商，但他沉迷于泰勒主义和他所谓的“唯一最佳方法”。宇宙中做任何工作都有一个“唯一最佳方法”。据说吉尔布雷斯是那个设置外科医生说“手术刀，镊子”，你知道，然后他们把它放在他手掌里的人。据说那是吉尔布雷斯。弗兰克崇拜泰勒，但正是他的妻子莉莲留下了真正的遗产。
to offices, to schools, to hospitals. In fact, Harvard Business School built much of its early curriculum around Taylor's ideas. Taylorism was even brought into the American home by two of his closest disciples, a couple named Frank and Lily and Gilbreath. Frank and Lily and Gilbeth, they're a married couple. Frank is a brick contractor, but he becomes obsessed with Taylorism and what he calls the one best way. There's a one best way for doing any job in the universe. And supposedly Gilbert is the guy who sets up the thing where the surgeon goes scalpel, foreseps, you know, and they put it in his palm. Supposedly that's Gilbert. Frank worshipped Taylor, but it's his wife, Lillian, who left the real legacy.
莉莲·吉尔布雷斯实际上是家政学的创始人。莉莲对家庭所做的就像泰勒对工厂所做的那样。她进行了研究，为女性做鸡蛋、洗衣服、洗碗计时。她沉迷于最大化她所谓的“幸福分钟”。但正如你可以想象的那样……它很少减少工作量。工作只是转移到了其他任务上，或者对任务的期望提高了。最终，这确实也是泰勒主义的影响。
Lillian Gilbert is actually sort of the founder of home economics. Lillian does for the home what Taylor does for the factory. She conducted studies where she timed women making eggs, doing laundry, doing the dishes. She was obsessed with maximizing what she called, quote, happiness minutes. But as you can imagine... Rarely does it decrease the amount of work. It just work moves to some other task or the expectations for the task go up. In the end, this really is the impact of Taylorism, too.
人们最终为了稍微多一点的钱做了更多的工作。我的意思是，关于泰勒的经典观察是，他有，我不知道，我编这些数字，但他有140人，假设，他把它减少到45人左右。那45人的工资稍微涨了一点，但涨幅没有管理层节省的钱多。所以他们为了稍微多一点的钱更努力地工作，而他们并没有实现休闲的梦想。如果你以前听说过效率福音，你可能知道这个想法，即洗碗机或洗衣机的发明，并没有突然让女性的生活多出几个小时。这是围绕人工智能的主要怀疑之一。
People end up doing more work for slightly more money. I mean, the classic observation about Taylor is that he's got, I don't know, I'm going to make these numbers up, but he's got 140 people, let's say, and he reduces that to something like 45. And the wages of those 45 go up a little bit, but they don't go up as much as the savings to management. So they're working harder for slightly more money, and they don't realize the dream of leisure. If you've heard about the gospel of efficiency before, you're probably aware of this idea that the invention of the dishwasher or their laundry machine, didn't suddenly give women back hours of their lives. This is one of the major skepticism around AI.
人们最终为了多赚一点点钱而做了更多的工作。我的意思是，关于泰勒的经典观察是，他有，我不知道，我这些数字是编的，但他有140个人，比如说，他把人数减少到大约45人。这45人的工资确实涨了一点，但涨幅远不及管理层节省下来的成本。所以他们为了多赚一点点钱而更加努力地工作，却并没有实现休闲的梦想。如果你以前听说过效率福音，你可能知道这样一个观点，即洗碗机或洗衣机的发明并没有让女性突然多出几个小时的生活时间。这是围绕人工智能的主要怀疑论之一。
It's like, okay, maybe these machines make us more efficient, but more efficient to do what exactly? Usually, the answer is more work. In a way, this is probably the realist, maybe the sneakiest legacy of Bundy and Taylor. Because at some point, this impulse towards surveillance and efficiency stopped coming from the bosses, and it started coming from us.
就像是，好吧，也许这些机器让我们更有效率，但更有效率到底是为了什么？通常答案是更多的工作。在某种程度上，这可能是邦迪（Bundy）和泰勒（Taylor）留下的最现实、也许也是最阴险的遗产。因为在某个时刻，这种对监控和效率的冲动不再来自老板，而是开始来自我们自己。
The idea of self-regulation as a moral virtue is really important. You know, this is Weber's point, that we all become our own jailers. Why do I work? I have tenure. Why do I work hard? I'm my own jailer, right? It's a personal obligation to work. It's not that there's a guy standing next to me saying, work, you dog, right?
将自我调节视为一种道德美德的想法非常重要。你知道，这就是韦伯（Weber）的观点，我们都成了自己的狱卒。我为什么要工作？我有终身教职。我为什么要努力工作？我是我自己的狱卒，对吧？工作是一种个人义务。并不是旁边有个家伙站在那儿说，干活吧，你这只狗，对吧？
I've internalized the impulse to work. It's become a moral imperative for me. And for most of us, people are. will work because they have to earn a living. They work because they have to make money. But there's also a sense that it's a duty and not working as a waste of your talents or it's sinful or it's sloth, right? The morality of working hard is not a new concept. The Protestant work ethic and all that has been around since the first settlers. But the difference now is that morality has been powered by clock time. You're constantly self-surveilling. There's a kind of identification of the person with their watch.
我已经内化了工作的冲动。它对我来说已经成为一种道德准则。对于我们大多数人来说，人们工作是因为他们必须谋生。他们工作是因为他们必须赚钱。但同时也有一种感觉，认为这是一种责任，不工作就是浪费你的才华，或者是有罪的，或者是懒惰的，对吧？努力工作的道德观并不是一个新概念。新教伦理等等自第一批定居者以来就一直存在。但现在的区别在于，这种道德观是由时钟时间驱动的。你一直在自我监控。人与他们的手表之间存在一种认同感。
This idea that we've become identified with time, with our output, with how good we are based on how much we worked, it might seem like it snuck up on us. But if you look back at the ads from the very beginning of this industry, all the way back to the 1880s, you can see that this was kind of the point all along. Mike showed me one of these ads from 1888 that I think is kind of amazing. It's a cartoon of a little round, stout guy, and he's looking at his watch. The ad is made up of six little drawings of a man, the same man over and over again. In the first drawing, he's looking at his watch, looking normal. Then in the next figure, he's looking at his watch, but now he's a little bit rounder. And in the next one, he's even more round.
这种认为我们已经与时间、与我们的产出、与我们根据工作量来衡量自身价值的想法，似乎是悄悄地潜入我们的生活。但如果你回顾这个行业最初的广告，一直追溯到1880年代，你会发现这其实一直都是重点。迈克（Mike）给我看了其中一张1888年的广告，我觉得非常惊人。那是一幅卡通画，画着一个圆圆的、矮胖的家伙，他正在看他的手表。这则广告由六幅小图组成，画的是同一个人，一遍又一遍。在第一幅图中，他看着手表，看起来很正常。然后在下一幅图中，他看着手表，但现在他变得圆了一些。在下一幅图中，他变得更圆了。
Then numbers appear on his face. Then the minute hand and the hour hand appear on his belly. And he's looking at his watch, and he habitually looks at his watch so often that eventually he turns into a watch. This is supposed to sell watches. This was an advertisement to sell the clock. This was supposed to get people in 1888 to say, yeah, I want that. Yeah, that was our first thought. It's monstrous, right.
然后数字出现在他的脸上。接着分针和时针出现在他的肚子上。他看着他的手表，他习惯性地频繁看表，以至于最终他变成了一块手表。这本意是为了推销手表。这是一则推销时钟的广告。这本意是让1888年的人们说，是的，我想要那个。是的，那是我们的第一个想法。这很可怕，对吧。
But it's the safety and security of being somebody who's under the discipline of timekeeping. I think that's what they're offering. And we bought it because merging with a watch seemed like becoming something good. Well, you're not unruly. You're not one of the unruly classes. You're not one of those workers who they have to physically. surveil, you're not one of those workers who's truculent and potentially lazy, you're not disruptive, you're not going to be the subject of police interest, because it indicates your
但这就是成为一个受时间管理纪律约束的人所带来的安全感和保障。我想这就是他们所提供的。我们买了它，因为与手表融合似乎变成了一件好事。嗯，你不是不守规矩的。你不是那些不守规矩的阶层之一。你不是那些他们必须进行物理监控的工人之一，你不是那些倔强且可能懒惰的工人之一，你不是破坏者，你不会成为警察关注的对象，因为它表明了你的
safety as a citizen of an industrial society. There's a merger of self and object that goes on, but the analogy to me would be to this compulsive checking of your devices, you know, always synchronizing yourself to the mothership. I want to go back to the brothers who started all of this. The brothers who began this revolution of mechanized time in the workplace, Willard and Harlow Bundy. Because their ending is kind of tragic and also kind of telling. These two brothers, Willard, the tinkerer who made the clock, Harlow, the businessman who figured out how to market it, they'd struck gold. But as the company expanded and became less about inventing and more about selling,
作为工业社会公民的安全性。这里发生了一种自我与物体的融合，但对我来说，类比就是这种对设备的强迫性检查，你知道，总是让自己与母舰同步。我想回到开启这一切的兄弟俩。开启这场工作场所机械化时间革命的兄弟，威拉德（Willard）和哈洛·邦迪（Harlow Bundy）。因为他们的结局有点悲剧，也有点发人深省。这两兄弟，威拉德是制造时钟的修补匠，哈洛是想出如何营销它的商人，他们发了大财。但随着公司扩张，重点不再是发明，而是销售，
the brothers started to come apart. While Harlow gained more and more power, Willard was being system. systematically phased out. He went from superintendent of his own company to a lowly contract employee, working out of a room on the fifth floor that he had to rent. Willard's son even begged Harlow to pay Willard more money. He had approached Harlow one day and said, I think my father should be making much more money. These are his clocks, his inventions, his life's work. Harlow responds with, no, he's signed a contract. He's being paid adequately. Maybe Harlow started to see his brother as one of those slackers in the Bundy Clock ads,
兄弟俩开始分道扬镳。当哈洛获得越来越多的权力时，威拉德却被系统性地边缘化了。他从自己公司的负责人变成了卑微的合同工，在五楼一个他必须租用的房间里工作。威拉德的儿子甚至恳求哈洛给威拉德更多的钱。他有一天找到哈洛说，我认为我父亲应该赚更多的钱。这些是他的时钟，他的发明，他一生的心血。哈洛回应说，不，他签了合同。他得到的报酬是足够的。也许哈洛开始把他的兄弟看作是邦迪时钟广告中那些懒汉之一，
just trying to cheat his boss out of more money. Whatever it was. The brother's feud went on for about two years, and Harlow eventually gets sick of it. So he ended up firing his own brother. Willard tries to start his own clock company, but Harlow sues him, over and over again. The brothers stayed in legal battles for the rest of his own. stood our lives and never again spoke in person.
只是想从老板那里骗更多的钱。不管是什么原因。兄弟俩的争执持续了大约两年，哈洛最终厌倦了。所以他最终解雇了自己的兄弟。威拉德试图创办自己的时钟公司，但哈洛一次又一次地起诉他。兄弟俩在余生中一直处于法律纠纷中，再也没有亲自交谈过。
The lawsuits drain Willard's family of resources, and in 1907, only four years after striking out on his own, he dies. For Willard, the lifelong inventor, the craftsman hero of our story, for him to end up like this in a rented room on the fifth floor, irrelevant in his own company, I think you can argue that this is the outcome of the thing he invented, the employee time clock. Because whether he intended it or not, it started a process that helped strip the craftsmanship and skill from the hands of the working people.
诉讼耗尽了威拉德家庭的资源，1907年，在他自立门户仅四年后，他就去世了。对于威拉德，这位终身发明家，我们故事中的工匠英雄，最终落得如此下场，在五楼的一间出租屋里，在自己的公司里变得无关紧要，我认为你可以说这是他发明的产物，即员工打卡钟。因为无论他是否有意，它开启了一个过程，帮助剥夺了劳动人民手中的工艺和技能。
It turned the men who made the machines into machines themselves. Meanwhile, Harlow stayed high up in the company. He retired, built a 10-bedroom palace in Pasadena, and left his wife multiple millions in today's dollars. The company, in the end, merged with a few others to become none other than IBM. Reporter and producer Ellie Lightfoot. A history of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. This episode was produced by Ellie Lightfoot.
它把制造机器的人变成了机器本身。与此同时，哈洛在公司里高高在上。他退休了，在帕萨迪纳建造了一座10间卧室的宫殿，并给他的妻子留下了相当于今天数百万美元的遗产。最终，该公司与几家公司合并，成为了IBM。记者兼制片人艾莉·莱特福特（Ellie Lightfoot）。《美国历史与100件物品》是99% Invisible和BBC Studios的制作。由我罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）主持和策划。本集由艾莉·莱特福特制作。
Our other producers are Priscilla Alabi and Brenna Dahldorf. Our associate producer is Isaac Fisher. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Mixing by Iver Manley. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2. From BBC Studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell.
我们的其他制片人是普里西拉·阿拉比（Priscilla Alabi）和布伦娜·达尔多夫（Brenna Dahldorf）。我们的助理制片人是艾萨克·费舍尔（Isaac Fisher）。本系列由安妮·布朗（Annie Brown）和考特尼·哈雷尔（Courtney Harrell）编辑。混音由艾弗·曼利（Iver Manley）完成。事实核查由艾米·布拉肯（Amy Bracken）完成。我们的主题曲由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作。来自99% Invisible，我们的执行制片人是凯西·2（Kathy 2）。来自BBC Studios，我们的执行制片人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。
Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright. Artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Serious XM Podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. And BBC Studios is headquartered in Beautiful. White City, West London. If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider,
我们的制作协调员是珊·帕莱（Shan Palais），制作经理是梅布尔·芬尼根·赖特（Mabel Finnegan Wright）。艺术作品由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。99% Invisible是Serious XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。BBC Studios总部位于西伦敦美丽的白城。如果你想联系我们或有物品供我们考虑，
email us at 100 objects at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请发送电子邮件至100objects@99PI.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。